welcome back to be rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of Rick and
Morty season four episode 10 the season
finale star more - Rick turn to the
Jerry an episode that thankfully took a
deep drag on that continuity and
delivered on the bet clone and
birdperson plot lines that we weren't
sure if they were gonna bring back
obsessively watching the show and
reminding ourselves of loose plot
threads pays off for a moment until you
realize this is just a TV show and who
knows if we'll also be here before we
get more episodes of it hey-oh what
better reason to scrub back through this
episode for all the hidden animation
jokes and Easter eggs for even more
reasons to laugh and for a deeper
discussion of the ending and the amazing
song don't look back with Tammy voice
actor Cassie Steele check out
yesterday's episode for explained ok
this episode opens with space Beth
confirming that Beth was indeed cloned
back in season 3 episode 9 the ABCs of
Beth we see how this Beth has quickly
evolved into a badass just like her
father Rick her armor and helmet is
actually similar to the helmets we saw
Rick and Morty we're in the Morty's mind
blowers memory she's killing Federation
ground flights as Rick is always enjoy
doing space Beth also has a scar over
her eye just like versions of Rick had
and tells from the Citadel and she's got
a crew son of a [ __ ] that includes a
female squanch squad jet we'll call her
and a female core populace Michael from
populous Michelle I presume this
episode's title is obviously a nod to
Star Wars Return of the Jedi and it's
filled with a ton of digs at Star Wars
yeah this ad is mapping the Death Star
concept over iPhone upgrades the way the
Star Wars franchise just keeps recycling
the Death Star with bigger and more
effective upgrades of it that are
essentially the same thing because they
always seem to have a glaring loophole
design flaw the NX v is sponsored by
Wrangler jeans which it's designed to be
unable to destroy which becomes it's
dumb design flaw it's also a callback to
the Federation's obsession with pants
from their battle in the season 3
premiere
Beth and her crew lead what's called the
defiance which is this episode's version
of the rebellion in Star Wars which
becomes the resistance in the sequel
trilogy and the new improved Galactic
Federation is just like how the Empire
became the first order it's all the same
[ __ ] space Beth learns that Rick rigs
her with a neck bomb implant just like
the ones the Suicide Squad and actually
a ton of other pop culture stories
behind her in her home our spare Android
parts and x-rays show how her body is
filled with cybernetic enhancements just
like Rix's including a plate on her
skull enhancements on her shoulder and
lower arms her breastplate and wiring
through her spine back at the Smith home
Rick gets out of therapy by goading
Morty and summer to fight over an
invisibility belt who looks like you to
have to fight about why you can't
control your kids good thing dr. Wong's
got an opening by Europe and don't let
him divide us since Harry had that
don't let him divide us locked and
loaded knowing that Beth was about to
call him out also she calls Jerry a bad
father which is the same realization
Rick arrives at at the end of this
episode
oh [ __ ] I'm a terrible father proving
that despite Rick's attempts to avoid
therapy he ended up putting himself the
reversion of it Rick's ironic self
therapy starts right away when he seals
himself in the garage in his family
therapy mode only to face space Beth
she has an implant that allows her to
these shifts super fast toward him but
not through a grid fence and powered by
the same kind of tech Rick in space Beth
have a Pokemon battle that throws a red
pokeball Rick throws a blue one meaning
it's a great ball looks as though Beth
is using a fire-type Pokemon which makes
it logical that Rick sees in a
water-type I'm basing that on the blue
color in that back fin so yeah makes
sense
Rick's savages it it's super effective
love the type advantage application
there I would expect nothing less
considering Rick and Morty has his own
pokemon style game some are uses the
invisibility belt to stalk her hunky
crush but I love the details on his
crummy home crappy clothes sundry and
Christmas lights still hanging a mailbox
just left open a bog on the roof a swing
set rested in the backyard
underground dirt patches on the lawn a
crack in the fence and yeah he's got a
farmer's tan of course this twig these
summers crushed Morty's billhook with
tiny big man jr. and in this dude's
hallway there's this insane photo of him
as a younger kid wearing a meth Gator
shirt sitting on the lap of a woman
wearing a corn on the cob top evoking
the terrified
on a cob planet all while this older
drunk dude and underwear he yells at
them so many red flags in one frame for
summer to stay the hell away from this
guy in this life Rick and space Bev go
to Shoney's Rick's favorite restaurant
from the season three premiere the place
he used to screw ro for the Federation
as they do again in this episode also
maybe a little clue that we could be
seeing another simulation here Rick has
some amazing tech that catches his spit
out beer and lifts it back into his mug
so we can resume drinking it to new drop
wasted very efficient in the TV and the
Shoney's is a Sunni brand morty peeps on
the honeybees cheerleaders and summer
catches Morty by calling shower fire
which does something that makes no sense
it remember Morty and Rick stripped down
in the shower he's back in the M night
civilians episode the Federation ship
for no reason vaporizes the goalposts I
guess kind of the way students randomly
storming the field after an upset win
randomly take these down as well Susan
Sarandon returns to voice the therapist
dr. Wang last seen in the pickle Rick
episode at her desk there's a doodle of
a stick figure with boobs drawn on it
Rick and Beth were right last episode
when they joked that therapists were
kinky okay we need dr. Wong this is the
Great British Bake Off TV gives British
people prizes for baking Jerry and Tammy
returns though Jerry briefly forgets her
name just like the gronckle might at the
top of the episode who couldn't remember
Beth Smith because it was too generic
Jerry it's got a bug brain
Jerry tries to stop Tammy this hey
uselessness comes back this episode
outside on the street there's a gas
station called greenhouse gas 248 for
regular in 322 for premium meaning the
gas with the bigger carbon footprint is
crazy discounted Rick uses previously
rigged booby traps in the therapy office
with a lot of voice-activated escape
contingencies these are all good points
I need to take a long look at myself
this shows that dr. Wong's analysis of
Rick and that pickle week episode was so
threatening to Rick that's had he been
ever dragged back into therapy he
prepared to use scripted responses to
get out of it his old family therapy
protocol was thorough as he learned
nothing from that episode or maybe
learned a lot depends on how you see
therapy during the chase they fly by the
my man mailman and Rick surrenders by
offering fast food it's amazing that
they work this and consider in every ad
break this season his teacher that crazy
windy Zaid Tammy returns her face and
neck back covered and burns from Rick's
fires earlier Morty and summers save
them from siblings to invisible to
working together it's not Citizen Kane
but what compete with whatever's going
on here you know some meta joking for
the writers comparing Morty and summers
underdeveloped and already finished
conflict this episode to one of the most
praised films of all time but invisible
summer breaks Tami's leg couch and Rick
shooter made me go to a wedding and you
killed my best friend I should have said
that one first yes Rick's big gripe from
wedding squatchers wasn't Tami's
betrayal of his best friend it was the
fact that he had to go to a wedding to
begin with look folks you've seen our
past episodes and you know we're big
fans of manscaped we love their products
and the Pew plunge that they let us make
when we're talking about it so we're
proud to announce that there's a brand
new product that we can make puns about
the man scaped weed whacker nose and ear
hair trimmer yes as rough as it can be
when your pubes get a rude and crude
attitude it's even worse when the air is
poking out of your head holes get too
swole why more people were seen your
nose and ears than they see your naughty
bits on a regular basis you don't want
those people to freak out when you got
sideburns and your mouth
79% of partners in a recent poll said
that nose hair was a major turnoff keep
your loved ones happy by bushwhacking
your booger bristles manscape spent over
a year working on the weed way
and it uses proprietary skin-safe
technology from their lawnmower body
trimmer
there's no snags and saws or fear near
your ear it's water-resistant and
intelligently designed to match the
contours of your nose plus it's way less
painful than plucking have you ever
tweeze some nose hair and turn it into
that Peter Parker crying mean manscaped
is hooking you up with their new
performance package which includes a
lawnmower three-point / below the waist
grooming plus their new weed whacker
nose and ear hair trimmer to round out
your manscaping routine so get 20% off
in free shipping winning use the promo
code two stars 20 and manscaped calm
that's promo code stars 20 for 20
percent off at manscape com see our link
in the video's description the NX battle
station voice changes for the planet
suggesting it has an insert planet here
part in its script congratulations
earth on being destroyed by the mx-5 and
Rick begrudgingly participates in a Star
Wars type plot wiping out the grapple
Knights like stormtroopers they have two
puppet Tami's corpse to scan or face
summer try unlocking that door by
scanning your highschool friends dead
face her eyes are closed
I'm already opened the left one I've got
the right the way she lived / serialized
solid wordplay there the writers calling
themselves a pour-over using a character
while they get multiple uses from her
corpse in the scene and scanning her
like a serial number
morty and summer call out the awkward
kiss between Luke and Leia before George
Lucas decided they were siblings
oh yeah we're like Luke and Leia except
no kissing part what's another famous
brother-sister team the Hansel and
Gretel all right those two were yeah
she's referring to that 2012 Hansell and
Gretel witch hunters movie with Jeremy
Renner all of its creepy and sexual
vibes something my buddy Allison wrote a
very funny sketch about when we got to
wear lederhosen like all of my old
sketch props and costumes the lederhosen
burned in the fire check out the latest
episode a big question for that tea
Jerry peas while invisible you can see
that the urine pulls up around the
outline of its shoe
birdperson AKA phoenix person returns
his entrance is a birch like a bird on a
cuckoo clock
given bird person and Timmy's various
kinks would not be surprised if the
cuckoo would be his bird of choice via
on this battle is incredible dan Hartman
range scream and then we cut to x-ray
mode to show the job rone shatter a nod
to the Mortal Kombat animation you can
see Rick's cybernetic arm in the x-ray
mode in his skeleton which extends later
on this battle to punch birdperson the
same x-ray effect shows bird person's
drill attacking Rick's heart but a metal
shield forms over the hearts in bins the
drill tip now as I mentioned before that
next five cannot disintegrate Wrangler
jeans leaving them floating behind after
people get zapped similar to the Tom
Cruise war the world's remake in which
the Martian tripod for whatever reason
zaps human flesh but not their clothes
actually because it looked cool the
rapture II I love that movie
Rick weaponized this pieces of the wall
to attack bird person and then he opens
up a portal and flip some off as he
falls through similar to Peter quill
against Thanos and infinity war re-watch
a breakdown of that movie is coming this
week and the two Beth's work really well
together maybe we could do like a Parent
Trap thing together sometime as long as
you mean the Lindsay Lohan version
actually yeah it's another weirdly
specific nod to the 1998 Lindsay loing
Parent Trap where she plays both of the
twins who scheme because twins always
have to scheme in movies where they
don't represent a lean Mills version in
which the twins are blonde and she says
naturally in that British accent because
Lowen had to play the British version of
herself - I know a lot of that movie I
saw it as a kid and I don't feel any
shame because I love that movie - Morty
and some are disabled - in X 5 dammit
where do you fix your underwear I saw
your balls for a second that's on you
risking ending up on a list here the
animators stuck in a little tear on
Morty's underwear moving on
birdperson blast ripped to pieces till
Rick's entrails spill out revealing even
more cybernetic patches probably
allowing his digestive system to absorb
alcohol more efficiently notice that
when he drinks his booze it spills out
what are the tubes
jerry stops birdperson from killing them
all by week in dead burning ain't a nice
corpse distracting him long enough for
space Beth to just flip his on and off
switch that's it that's all it took of
course Rick overthought it now Rick kept
the memory of Beth's cloning and a
memory vial from the Morty's mind-blower
episode as the Beth's decide they don't
need to know the truth space Beth makes
rick flinch with a fist just like Rick
and
summer did to each of the bullies they
jumped annex gonna give it to you
montage the memory reveals that Beth let
rick decide which version to keep in
which version to release on the table
behind bet is a photo of young beth with
the birthday cake in the memories that
he transfers includes beth hold a
newborn morty beth and jerry's wedding
photo and that birthday memory with
Rick's wife Diane Sanchez mystery woman
we still know very little about now
behind young Beth is a teddy bear
in that same camcorder that Rick used to
record this birthday memory all this
from that simple Rick's commercial in
the tales from the Citadel episode so
rick is reviewing the memories most
precious to him about his daughter that
the Rick's of the Citadel used to
stabilize a Rick in a loop to produce
that nostalgic brain chemical just to
flavor this simple Rick's bar so you
know this is heartbreaking
Rick randomizes which Beth is a clone
which is a real one his machine does
head ball and cut maneuver now Rick is
watching this whole memory on the
projector screen and it appears he's
watching it from a third-person
perspective meaning that from his
vantage point there in the garage he
might have been able to keep his eye on
the clone and figure out which was which
but we could wait for the projector
screen we never see the ending of the
switcheroo so in our point of view it's
left a mystery but it doesn't matter
Rick feels alienated from both Beth's
for the past 11 episodes he's been
willing to live with the fact that the
daughter he's been living in the house
with might just be a fake copy and
either way this real Beth wasn't his
original death he and Morty swapped into
this reality in season one from c-137
who knows how many times Rick did that
before then that's why he feels so alone
in the music that underscores this is
amazing it's don't look back by Cotto me
and Rick and Morty composer Ryan elder I
went into the deeper connection of the
lyrics and Rick's blamed I know I'm
plugging it a lot because it's great
there's more to this show that just
hidden Dickies folks the post-credits
team follows Jerry's adventures as
invisible garbage truck Jerry I hate to
go frame-by-frame through body
explosions but the two striving the
convertible blows up horrific Lee his
eyes pop out of his face so he's just a
flesh mask for one frame it's just an
animator decided to put that in there
and Jerry like an idiot steps right into
the blood all kinds of gross human
fluids all over that shoe the dumpster
next to the pimp has graffiti readings
stank the alleys and dumpsters on the
show tend to be tagged with words like
stank and poo and lastly Jerry passes an
animated version of Mike Mendell the
longtime animation producer on shows
like Rick and Morty in the Simpsons he
passed away late last year this
premier also included a cameo by that
beloved crew member nice to the
animators to show some more love in this
finale thanks for joining me this season
of Rick and Morty sadly it really just
flew by follow me on Instagram and
Twitter a TA vos followed me rock stars
and socials and subscribe to this
channel on YouTube for breakdowns a bit
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]